in this segment we introduce the concept
of continuous random variables and their
characterization in terms of probability
density functions or PDFs for short let
us first go back to discrete random
variables a discrete random variable
takes values in a discrete set there is
a total of 1 unit of probability
assigned to the possible values and the
PMF tells us exactly how much of this
probability is assigned to each value so
we can think of the bars in the PMF as
point masses with positive weight that
sit on top of each possible numerical
value and we can calculate the
probability that the random variable
falls inside an interval by adding all
the masses that sit on top of that
interval so for example if we're looking
at the interval from A to B the
probability of this interval is equal to
the sum of the probabilities of these
three masses that fall inside this
interval on the other hand a continuous
random variable will be taking values
over a continuous range for example the
real line or an interval on the real
line in this case we still have one
total unit of probability mass that is
assigned to the possible values of the
random variable except that this unit of
mass is spread all over the real line
but it is not spread in a uniform manner
some parts of the real line have more
mass per unit length some have less how
much mass exactly is sitting on top of
each part of the real line is described
by the probability density function this
function plotted here which we denote
with this notation the letter F will
always indicate that we are dealing with
the PDF and the subscript will indicate
which random variable we're talking
about we use the probability density
function to calculate the probability
that X lies in a certain interval let's
say the interval from A to B and we
calculated by finding the area
under the PDF that sits on top of that
interval so this area here the shaded
area is the probability that X takes
values in this interval think of
probability as snowfall there is one
pound of snow that has fallen on top of
the real line the PDF tells us the
height of the snow accumulated over a
particular point we then find the weight
of the overall amount of snow sitting on
top of an interval by calculating the
area under this curve of course
mathematically area under the curve is
just an integral so the probability that
X takes values in this interval is the
integral of the PDF over this particular
interval what property should the PDF
have by analogy with the discrete case a
PDF must be non-negative because we do
not want to get negative probabilities
in the discrete case the sum of the PMF
entries has to be equal to one in the
continuous case X is certain to lie in
the interval between minus infinity and
plus infinity so letting a be minus
infinity and B plus infinity we should
get a probability of one so the total
area under the PDF when we integrate
over the entire real line should be
equal to one these two conditions are
all that we need in order to have a
legitimate PDF we can now give a formal
definition of what a continuous random
variable is a continuous random variable
is a random variable whose probabilities
can be described by a PDF according to a
formula of this type an important point
the fact that a random variable takes
values on a continuous set is not enough
to make it what we call a con
Dean use random variable for a
continuous random variable we're asking
for a bit more that it can be described
by a PDF that the formula of this type
is valid now once we have the
probabilities of intervals as given by a
PDF we can use additivity to calculate
the probabilities of more complicated
sets for example if you are interested
in the probability that X lies between 1
and 3 or that X lies between 4 & 5 so
this is the probability that X falls in
a region that consists of two disjoint
intervals we find the probability of the
union of these two intervals by
additivity by adding the probabilities
of the two intervals since these
intervals are disjoint and then we can
use the PDF to calculate the
probabilities of each one of these
intervals according to this formula at
this point you may be wondering what
happened to the sample space in all this
discussion well there is still an
underlying sample space lurking in the
background and different outcomes in the
sample space result in different
numerical values for the random variable
of interest and when we talk about the
probability that X takes values between
some numbers a and B what we really mean
is the probability of those outcomes for
which the resulting value of X lies
inside this particular interval so
that's what probability means on the
other hand once we have a PDF in our
hands we can completely forget about the
underlying sample space
we can carry out any calculations we may
be interested in by just working with
the PDF so as we move on in this course
the sample space will be moved off stage
there will be less and less mention of
it and we will be working just directly
with PDFs or with pmf's if we are
dealing with discrete random variables
let us now build a little bit on our
understanding of what PDFs really are by
looking at probabilities of small
intervals let us look at an interval
that starts at some a and goes up to
some number a plus Delta so here Delta
is a positive number but who are
interested in the case where Delta is
very small let us look at the
probability that X falls in this
interval the probability that X lies
inside this interval is the area of this
region on the other hand as long as F
does not change too much over this
little interval which will be the case
if we have a continuous density F then
we can approximate the area of this
region by the area of a rectangle where
we keep the height constant the area of
this rectangle is equal to the height
which is the value of the PDF at the
point a times the base of the rectangle
which is equal to Delta so this gives us
an interpretation of PDFs in terms of
probabilities of small intervals if we
take this factor of Delta and send it to
the other side in this approximate
equality we see that the value of the
PDF can be interpreted as probability
per unit length so PDFs are not
probabilities their densities their
units are probability per unit length
now if the probability per unit length
is finite and the length Delta is sent
to zero we will get zero probability
more formally if we look at this
integral and we let B to be the same as
a then we obtain the probability that X
is equal to a and on that side we get an
integral over a 0 length interval and
that integral is going to be zero so we
obtain that the probability that X takes
a value equal to a specific particular
point that probability is going to be
equal to zero
so for a continuous random variable any
particular point has zero probability
yet somehow collectively the infinitely
many points in an interval together will
have positive probability is this a
puzzle not really that's exactly what
happens also with the ordinary notion of
length single points have zero length
yet by putting together lots of points
we can create a set that has a positive
length and the final consequence of the
fact that individual points have zero
length using the additivity axiom the
probability that a random variable takes
values inside an interval is equal to
the probability that a random variable
takes a value of a plus the probability
that a random variable takes a value of
B plus the probability that a random
variable is strictly between a and B
according to our discussion this term is
equal to zero and this term is equal to
zero and so we conclude that the
probability of a closed interval is the
same as the probability of an open
interval when calculating probabilities
it does not matter
whether we include the endpoints or not